this is what your hair looks like when
it's dirty and this is what shampoo does
to that dirt surfactants form these
micelles around the dirt which is what
grabs onto dirt and oil it's like no no
I don't want to go that was the dirt
screaming for its life
Erica Douglas has been a cosmetic
chemist for more than a decade and today
she's going to break down the
ingredients and head and shoulders
classic clean dandruff shampoo it's
about to get messy
it's actually a fairly simple formula
not a lot of ingredients that means that
there's not a lot of fluff in this
formula Erica broke down the ingredients
into these categories let's start here
one of the first ingredients that I see
is pyrethion zinc this is one of the
most common actives used in the Cosmetic
space to fight dandruff without this
ingredient it's just the shampoo
dandruff is actually caused by a fungus
called malesia and it feeds on the oil
the FDA allows up to two percent of
pyrethion zinc and products like this
shampoo which are applied and then
rinsed off the classic clean formula
uses pyrethion Zinc at one percent but
in the EU they actually ban pyrethion
zinc from being used as a cosmetic
active according to the company the EU
version uses this ingredient instead of
pyrethion zinc so the active ingredient
handles the dandruff but surfactants
like these sulfates are what actually
clean the scalp surfactants are the
Soapy part of the shampoo it's what
causes the suds it's actually what is
pulling the dirt and the oil off of your
hair and scalp I believe that they are
using this as their primary surfactant
and the cochemyto propyl butane is the
secondary surfactant in this formula
surfactants work a little something like
this we're going to just use some
regular Pepper have it float on top of
some normal deionized water these
surfactants have their hydrophilic head
and their hydrophobic tails and so they
form these micelles around the dirt
which is what grabs onto dirt and oil
and helps it to remove it from the hair
and the scalp instantly you see how it
repels it it's like running from the
shampoo some surfactants create more
Suds than others but foam actually
doesn't dictate how well a shampoo is
cleaning your hair there are certain
surfactants that can produce a lot of
foam like this one but then there are
other surfactants that are or mild does
not mean that it's not working so foam
is kind of like for Aesthetics so we
call this the cylinder Shake method you
can see how much foam is going to last
and how it separates out a lot of hair
stylists view sulfates as being too
harsh I see sulfates as a great
surfactant when used in moderation and
they are also being formulated in
conjunction with other conditioning
agents that allow it to moisturize and
condition the hair at the same time
that's the job of this ingredient here
otherwise known as a silicone they help
to maintain the water level in your hair
this is water with just a little bit of
violet one colorant versus when I do the
same thing with dimethicone and
dimethicone just has a little bit of the
blue one colorant you notice how the
water went right through the sponge
that's because it's soaked in and went
straight to the bottom versus this
silicone stays right on top this is the
difference between when your hair there
is absorbing moisture versus using a pro
a silicone like dimethicone to help seal
the cuticle and maintain moisture
content silicones have really gotten
this bad rep they've been thought to
weigh the hair down or leave a build up
this is absolutely not true they have
the ability to stay on the hair to seal
the cuticles and they do come off the
hair when using a shampoo now for what
gives the shampoo its distinct look so
head and shoulders uses blue number one
and red 33 as their colorants and that's
how you get this really cool light blue
looking color in addition to the glycol
diastere which is used as a pearlizing
agent to give it that Pearl look I know
what the ratios are that they use that's
their proprietary information first I'm
going to start with my blue number one
okay and then we'll try to see what
happens when we add a little red 33 as
you can see I literally put less than a
gram in and that's how dark it got blue
1 and red 33 are both synthetic colors
approved for use in cosmetics with some
use restrictions some of the concerns
that come around synthetic colors would
be that it could potentially be an air
tint or an allergen for some people
according to the environmental working
group safety ratings blue one is marked
as high Hazard while red 33 is marked as
moderate a head and shoulders
representative reiterated that these
dies are FDA approved noting that the
classic clean formula is known for its
signature blue color and when it comes
to fragrance it just lists that they use
fragrance nothing else fragrance
contains 30 40 ingredients sometimes the
ingredients that make up a fragrance are
often proprietary but according to
Erica's scientific sniffer product has
Floral
and Aquatic notes while it's not listed
on the label Head and Shoulders does
list over 20 ingredients found in the
classic clean fragrance formulation
online including some considered
allergens in the EU and soon this could
become a more common practice a new law
was put into action which actually will
now require cosmetic products to list
fragrance allergens on the label going
into 2024. consistency is also a crucial
part of a shampoo's formulation some of
the ingredients that they're using to
give that thick creamy feel is glycol
diastere also the Gwar
hydroxypropyl trimodium chloride guar is
great conditioning detangling agent but
it also gives the formula some thickness
with salt can give you that thick feel
and while the final product feels thick
the most surprising thing about shampoo
formulations is that it's mostly water
any product that has water in it has the
potential to grow mold fungus bacteria
we don't want any of that stuff
different packages The Wall Street
Journal purchased had different
preservatives listed the preservative
used in this product is sodium benzoate
another version of the same product
lists these two additional preservatives
which have a high incidence with skin
allergies the company said it recently
shifted away from this preservative
combination to one with sodium benzoate
but products with the combination are
still currently sold on store shelves
before a product hits the Shelf one
crucial element must be tested that's
the pH we are measuring a pH of 7.3 for
this head and shoulders product this is
not abnormal but it is on the high end
of what I would normally see Head and
Shoulders said this reading is in line
with the standard range of its formulas
which it said remains America's number
one anti-dandruff shampoo with moisture
levels as they are and there are a few
things to note on the overall packaging
they claim that this bottle is paraben
free I would agree that this is a
paraben free product the paraben issue
is a very provocative topic there have
been some preliminary studies that show
that there could be possible linkage
between parabens and cancer there's no
conclusive scientific data that links
paraben usage and cosmetics directly to
cancer but the possibilities of it being
a carcinogen has provoked some
limitations on how this ingredient is
being used in the Cosmetic space and
Erica sees some opportunities for
improvements if I could change anything
about this formula I would probably add
a few more conditioning and moisturizing
agents just to give more functionality
and more control to the actual hair I
think that dandruff is a little
hush-hush because nobody wants to be
known as the snowflake I think a lot of
people associate dandruff with being
unclean but that's completely not true
we need to talk more about it
thank you
[Music]